is once again saying i want you  but they're also offering a pretty big  financial incentive upwards of fifty  thousand dollars in bonuses for highly  skilled recruits who sign up for a six  year hitch the army says the pandemic  has made it tough to get new soldiers  the way they've done for decades through  schools or community events  about two-thirds of our formation in  terms of recruiters across the united  states army have not done recruiting  outside of coveted conditions so we have  an obligation to get out now to start  selling you know the army  okay so the total package for new  recruits based on a combination of  career field qualifications length of  enlistment and the training start date  the army hoping the 50 thousand dollar  bonus will help fill vacancies in about  150 different career fields